[Música]
los pueblos más bonitos de francia
forman un club muy selecto compuesto por
159 miembros entre ellos en el corazón
de la región de auvernia está usón
el problema del sol es que todo está
cuesta arriba
ha cerrado a su pico volcánico a 600
metros de altura este pueblo fue una
fortaleza inexpugnable en el siglo 16
este pueblo es muy bonito y está muy
bien conservado hay piedras bonitas como
me gustan y lindos muros de piedra no ha
sido dañado por las nuevas
construcciones es eso encanto si lees la
piedra de auvernia es muy hermosa
[Música]
hasta hace poco ya no había negocios en
uso pero eso cambió cuando dos de sus
habitantes reabrieron el único albergue
del pueblo
[Música]
nos sentimos bien aquí nuestra vida se
construyó y nos casamos criamos a
nuestros hijos todo está en este pueblo
era algo esencial para mí tengo la
suerte de tener la vista de la cadena
montañosa de los guys eso es genial
cuando conocí a sophie mi esposa tuve la
oportunidad de visitar un sol y me
enamoré inmediatamente del pueblo en ese
momento no estábamos listos para
establecernos sólo teníamos 27 años pero
no queríamos perder la oportunidad así
que nos instalamos acá han pasado 17
años
no tenemos arrepentimientos en lo alto
del pueblo la iglesia románica se
encuentra ubicada en lo que alguna vez
fueron las murallas del castillo ahora
destruidas estos bancos de piedras se
llaman actuar del francés para bloquear
las mujeres de usón solían reunirse acá
hablar de ahí el nombre
usón es famoso por su piedra de color
negro que viene de las entrañas de la
tierra
[Música]
más
estamos en el corazón del volcán el
magma se fue por la chimenea las rocas
se cayeron y se solidificaron muy
rápidamente lo que dio lugar a estas
formas de órganos basálticos
[Música]
una espectacular acantilado que hace de
uso un lugar obligado en el camino de
los volcanes de bérnia
el pueblo de cantón que quiere decir la
brillante ciudadela en celta también fue
construido sobre un espolón rocoso y es
el orgullo de sus quince habitantes para
conservar sus viejas casas en los
acantilados esos locales no dudan en
lanzarse al vacío
en el pueblo hay algunas casas donde hay
mucha hierba la quitamos cada cinco años
es hermoso
vivimos en una región muy bonita
sermón nació y creció encanto
y todos tenían su propio jardín su
pequeño viñedo eran tiempos difíciles
pero éramos felices aunque no éramos
ricos éramos felices cuando llegaba la
navidad y recibíamos una naranja
tiene que ver con su origen el balón
sobre el trofeo
a vélez trofeos estos son buenos
recuerdos con las campanas cada semana
le tocaba el turno a alguien de tener
las llaves una semana éramos nosotros
los que íbamos a tocar las campanas
todos los días
incluso hoy en día tocar las campanas de
la iglesia todavía es visto como un
privilegio
[Aplausos]
me alegra arreglarlo todo la noche
anterior no puedo evitarlo le doy una
pequeña sacudida a nuestras lindas
campanas hay que cuidarlas para hacerlas
sonar de lo contrario no valen nada y
también es un placer para los ancianos
recordar los tiempos en que había bodas
muertes vida en el pueblo la iglesia era
la vida del pueblo era todo lo que había
nuestro camino nos lleva más al este en
la verde región de provenza se encuentra
cotignac este tranquilo pueblo está
situado al pie de un espectacular
peñasco que se puede descubrir paseando
por sus caminos de piedra y sus
callejones medievales cotignac fue
construido sobre un río
el caso el que fue desviado pasado en
medio del pueblo el río si el río pero
eso fue hace 500 años así es cómo se
formó el peñasco
sí sí es algo bueno estar en cotignac
eso es seguro
esto es la provenza en todo su esplendor
suspender el peñasco ofrece una
vertiginosa caminata si se sube el
acantilado se pasa por estrechas
galerías y casas trogloditas
[Música]
esta data de 1833 estábamos en una vieja
casa excavada en la roca con una fachada
en la mampostería
un gran patio de recreo para los niños
de cotignac
exploramos creíamos que éramos
exploradores casi como julio verde viaje
al centro de la tierra era el centro del
peñasco pero era muy divertido
lugares que dejan sin aliento y
habitantes felices de preservar su
patrimonio estas son algunas de las
claves de los pueblos más bonitos de
francia
[Música]